welcome back to the series on matrix
math this is matt from code tech
tutorials it's been a minute I've been a
little under the weather a little sick
so I smash the like button to help make
it better I don't know how it helps but
it does so please please do it and also
subscribe and turn notifications on
thank you very much
okay sub matrices and partitioning we're
going to talk a little bit about this
today is actually a pretty important
little subject that yeah and I find it
to be kind of cool so let's let's just
jump into it okay so a sub matrix is
okay well I mean let me throw up a
little matrix here say we have 1 2 3 5 7
2 1 4 8 7 6 9 2 1 1 1 okay that makes
easy so this is a 4 by 4 matrix and we
can sub matrix it by putting lines
through it like like so and have little
sub matrices so we'd have a matrix here
and here and here and here so we can
grab 4 sub matrixes out of it however
you can put these lines anywhere like
you can subdivide it like so and have a
matrix here a matrix here in matrix here
so you can subdivide it however you need
and that's the cool thing like you could
do it like this and you have a little 2
3 5 matrix there that's seven eight two
one there but we're going to keep it
simple and we're going to keep it nice
and squared for our examples so what you
can do here is you can
you can multiply two matrices together
say we had another another matrix and
say it's also a 4x4 I'm mainly layer for
this so what you can do is you can if
you have two matrices you're going to
multiply together you can subdivide or
partition and then multiply the
partitions together and just do a part
at a time which can often save you a lot
of work if you know you only need one
section of a matrix or you can also
break up the tax if it's a really giant
matrix that way you can handle it in
chunks because if you're trying to do
like a sixteen by sixteen by hand it's
gonna take so much space on a piece of
paper or whatever it is you're doing it
on so you might want to subdivide it up
and do pieces at a time so let me give
you a little example of the syntax we're
just going to use some letters here
we'll use just
say we have matrix a and
and rather than fill out every element
let's just let's just say it's a 2x8 no
no let's say it's a four by four it
isn't really matter for this example
four by four is fine but what is
important to know is that how it's
subdivided and we want to label each of
these so we'll call this matrix X we'll
call this one Y we'll call this one Z
and we'll call this one W and actually
you know let's let's start with W W X Y
Z and say we have matrix B and I mean
this one kind of big but oh well and
matrix B will be the same
oh say it's a 4x4 as well so if we're
evenly dividing it each of these are
going to be a little two by twos as you
can imagine you know four different
elements in each one and combined
together you get a 4x4 so this is just
the example we're using but I just want
to show you kind of how it works when
you multiply them together because
that's kind of the main thing you do
when you're partitioning usually unless
you're just grabbing a certain certain
row or something and you know you
partition off that first row
okay and we'll call this one when we
need some of the other letters let's
call it P Q
well come on ABCs come to me
RS pqrs so if we want to get the product
of these or multiply these together what
we can do is we can say look I think I
got enough room here a B is going to be
equal to don't want to make that a less
than sign
and if you remember the multiplication I
think that's tutorial four or five if
you go back if you're not sure about
multiplication is you do the row times
column saying so it would be well this
first quadrant would end up being let's
see W times P plus
x times R I got that right yeah so you
could calculate that up and get the
first quadrant there of the result or
the forest to buy two of the result and
you could do a similar thing for the
rest so for this one it's going to be W
Q
Plus
let's see what would this be X s there
we go
and down here we're gonna do about the
same thing we're gonna have I'll see Y P
whoops not hard P plus Z bar and this
last one of course is going to be make
sure that's right yeah y q+ let's see
yes so then you have it broken up and
you can do these in steps so you can
calculate this one and then this one in
this one then if you have a giant giant
matrix it just it just makes it a little
better sometimes to be able to do this
so that that's kind of the main thing
here we can also say going back to this
first example okay going back to this
first example well let's let's call this
a for this particular example a we could
say that things are a sub matrix so say
we have another matrix called B and it
is
is one two seven two we could say that B
is a sub matrix of a because it's in
this and we say where we cut it to get
that sub matrix so you can do that
anywhere so if you have another one say
one that's two three five
you could also say this is a sub C is a
sub matrix of a if you cut it like so
it's right there and you can also say a
is a sub matrix of itself with no cuts
so that's a thing - well that's pretty
much everything about sub matrices and
partitioning hope you enjoyed this
episode I'll see you guys in the next
one
please don't forget to Like subscribe
with notification bells on bells I don't
know how it works now they changed it or
you get to choose now apparently and I
appreciate all the support I hope you
guys are doing great with your
programming in your matrix mask I'll be
here ask me questions
whatever you want to do and I'll see you
guys in the next episode